how's britain doing on its climate
objectives is it getting down to net
zero
is it really reducing emissions as fast
as it says it is there are a lot of
questions when it comes to the data
on climate change and indeed on carbon
emissions and i want to start by just
kind of going through some of that data
and over the course of the coming months
we're going to have a lot more
of this stuff coming up for cop 26 and
we're going to be trying to ask
questions about that data in the same
way we've been asking questions about
the
the covert data as well and let's start
with kind of the big
story greenhouse gas emission this shows
you uk domestic greenhouse gas emissions
over the course
of the last few decades starts in 1990
because that's kind of the benchmark
here that a lot of people count this
stuff
about it's already always getting
emissions down from that 1990 level
down towards net zero by 2050 and where
are we with the latest
uh data well we've just had this out
from the government uh they say
the emissions fell by 8.9 in 2020
and just to put that into perspective
that is probably the data so there's
some question marks over here
some of the data sources but it looks
like it's the biggest year-on-year fall
that we've seen
since 1926 that was the year of the
general strike and in a way actually
there's kind of analogy there isn't
there
we had lockdown obviously in 2020 vast
parts of the economy basically shut down
similar thing with the general strike
you had a shutdown in activity and that
forced
activity into and also emissions to go
down very sharply
far more sharply actually than this down
by about 30 but the upshot of all of
that
is that the uk is getting closer to that
goal where is the goal well look
it is net zero you can see so down
towards zero by 2050 that's just a
straight line
that i've kind of extrapolated out there
and where are we at the moment where
we're more
or less halfway not quite halfway
actually we're not
over 50 in terms of our reduction yet
and it is worth saying as well
you've probably kind of guessed this but
this year that we're in at the moment so
2021 we're likely to see an increase in
emissions because we had that full
that lockdown fall last time around so
we're not quite halfway yes and
obviously we're halfway in terms of
dates
in terms of the years that have passed
30 years from 1990 30 years to go
but we're not at halfway in terms of the
emissions so more needs to be done on
that
um but let's not lose sight of the fact
that a lot has been done and actually
in an interesting sense like those shots
went back to 1990. this one goes all the
way back to 1855 so the latter stages of
the industrial revolution so you can
what you can see here
is carbon emissions coal you know as
coal-fired power stations
uh coal solders come in there uh you've
got steel works
the carbon emissions went up and up and
up and then they
peaked around kind of the early 1970s
and actually the interesting thing is
they've been falling
ever since and partly we'll get onto
this in a moment partly that's down to
you know actually cutting emissions more
efficient vehicles all of that stuff
that we know about
um you have more kind of renewable power
stations all of that
but partly actually it's also down to
economic trends and we'll discuss those
uh in a moment but for the time being
let's just ask that question so of those
emissions just over 400
uh million tons of emissions greenhouse
gas emissions where are they actually
coming from so 414 million tons of
carbon emissions greenhouse gas
emissions
i keep saying carbon greenhouse it's
mostly carbon but there are other
greenhouse gases as you'll see
i'm going to break it down though you
know a lot of people would say the
obvious big thing here is power stations
energy supply
actually that's only about it's kind of
19
and that includes refineries so that's
not the biggest chunk
of what this 414 business is
you know relatively big as well so
that's just businesses doing their jobs
but
transport is the biggest chunk of all
here's the interesting thing
while that bit energy supply is getting
smaller and smaller as you've got
you know more wind power more solar
power and so on more renewables
less coal fire power stations um the
transport
chunk isn't really getting that much
smaller that
that quickly now that might change when
you have electrification of vehicles but
that really is why a lot of focus is
going to be on transport
uh on vehicle electrification in the
next few years although some would say
hang on the government is freezing fuel
due to year after year
that might be part of the explanation
for why those emissions are still pretty
high and by the way not going down
i think as much as a lot of people had
expected uh during lockdown down quite a
bit but still
you'll expect that to go up in the next
few years then this is interesting
residential now this basically that's
your that's your boilers
you know that's that's houses across the
country and actually residential
could soon be bigger than energy supply
so
that is part of the explanation for why
this is going to be difficult to get
down to net zero because a lot of people
are going to have to replace their
boilers because that's going to be an
ever bigger part of this uh
this donut as it were of emissions that
we're talking our way through and then
you've got industries so
steel for instance cement you know
making these things actually generates
quite a lot of carbon we're not quite
sure actually how to deal with that
you've got other co2 emissions and then
you've got other greenhouse gases like
methane so
add that all up and then you've got the
414 that we're talking about
it just shows though it's not just about
kind of shutting down cold fire power
stations it's about
the entire spectrum of activities that
we do
across the economy now another thing
this is a really important thing and you
know
we'll probably kind of encounter this a
few times over the course of the next
few months
when we're talking about this this this
just this is going back to that original
kind of line it's a slightly different
uh series i've looked at here but it's
going back to the original line of
greenhouse gas emissions going down and
down and down great news isn't it
um but bear in mind okay i'm going to
fill that in bear in mind
what we're talking about here is
domestic emissions
so uk domestic emissions from anything
that's happening
within this country but here's the thing
we all know
there's also goods that we import from
china and other countries around the
world
which involve burning carbon uh to make
them
and so how do you account for that the
answer is
you can start to extrapolate that and so
we have a different data set here
that kind of extrapolates that and adds
that on so if we wanted to add on
emissions that came
from other countries around the world
well here's what it would look like
if you added on emissions that came from
imports from europe we'll
add those on there add on the emissions
that come from the us from china
as well and indeed from the rest of the
world and now have a look at that so
you've got domestic emissions at the
bottom
looks like it's getting lower and lower
and lower and it is indeed
but then you've got this other chunk of
emissions which are
imported emissions so when you've got
the total including imports let's
compare those two lines
they're quite different aren't they so
we're talking about net zero
but it's net zero for which of these and
the short answer is
according to the law it's net zero
getting those domestic emissions
uh down to zero and on that front we're
doing pretty well we used
you saw the chart earlier um this is a
slightly different data series so it
says we're only down by 31 percent but
even so
the key thing here is note the
difference domestic
emissions down by 30
total emissions so when you include
imports stuff from china
down by 16 percent they're down by
barely half
of that total so which which are we
actually going to look at net zero are
we going to look at domestic are we
going to look at the total when it comes
to domestic we might well stand a chance
of getting there when you look at the
total
we're a long way off that and so it's
worth just bearing that in mind when you
hear about all of these numbers
in the next few months the other thing i
want to do actually is show you
what looks like a similar chart but it's
making a slightly different point um
and this is quite important as well okay
this is again just domestic emissions
and it shows the uk
and we're down by kind of 40 depends on
how you measure it but we're down quite
a lot
uh since the beginning of the 1990s
let's look at other countries and how
they're doing so this is just their
remissions it's not imported emissions
it's just how much they are emitting
within their own countries
it's a comparable series here slightly
different data series like i say but it
shows you
that germany emissions fell as well not
by as much as the uk
how much of that is down to actual kind
of efficiency measures actual green
measures and how much of it is down to
the fact that germany remains a big
industrial center because you saw that
last chart didn't you saw that actually
part of the uk's fall was down to the
fact that we're importing this stuff
from overseas
that is one of those questions so you
know it's not immediately clear that
germany is down 30
and the uk down 40 that's all because of
green measures it's other things as well
the change in the
fabric of the economy then you've got
france down italy down as well
but now if we add on other countries
let's add on the us and see how this
picture of global emissions what we're
doing is layering on
these different emissions from different
countries we're going to get a sense of
what this looks like across
the world so add on the u.s and actually
suddenly
it looked like it was falling but now
maybe
it's rising actually it's rising so u.s
emissions up by five percent
over this period add on a few other
countries like japan
like canada canada by 22 so a lot of
mining
uh happening in canada at the moment a
lot of industry uh and then other
countries as well for instance
china and it just stands out enormously
there doesn't it so china up by 300
in terms of uh greenhouse gas emissions
from china and india up by 200
as well and you can probably barely make
out the uk
and other bits of europe there at the
bottom
a tiny sliver set against this massive
mountain of greenhouse gas emissions
from all over the world
and this really is the big story the uk
is statistically pretty insignificant
when it comes to all of this yes those
emissions might be falling but the big
picture across the world is that
actually
greenhouse gas emissions are going up
and up and up and no one is quite sure
when they're going to stop going up